all right good evening america at 7 pm
on the east coast and 6 p.m in god's
country which means it's time for fox
news prime time i'm pete heck seth and
tonight as brett did we start with joe
biden who emerged from his hiding to
finally take some questions from the
press
and after two hours of q a
we have to ask
what did we just watch
biden of course pulled out all of his
hits
look
look um so
look look very few schools are closing
over 95
are still open
95
are still open and i got strong thurman
to vote for it look again
how can i i'm taking too long answering
your questions i apologize
i think that
and despite plenty of awkward pauses and
lots of whispering
biden made sure to pat himself on the
back for the failure his presidency has
become
i didn't over promise
and but i have probably uh
outperformed what anybody thought would
happen
look um
i didn't over promise
but
i think if you take a look at what we've
been able to do
you'd have to acknowledge we made
enormous progress
yeah just uh just take a look at the
record
not sure what country sleepy joe is
waking up in or napping in
but not only have we failed to make
progress however he defines it under his
standard under biden but the country is
actually moving in the wrong direction
just look at how much more expensive
your life has become
in joe biden's america overall prices
are up seven percent your food will cost
you six percent more if you can find
some uh with bare shelves biden
gas is up almost fifty percent and
energy costs have jumped nearly thirty
percent that goes straight to your
bottom line
but go on joe continue to tell us how
good of a job how great of a job
you're doing
maybe the funniest or the saddest part
of all is that biden thinks none of this
is his fault
it's those pesky republicans who are
tripping him up
fooling him that tomfoolery and malarkey
at every chance
for a man who ran for president under
the guise of uniting the country
he sure is doing a lot of dividing
one thing i haven't been able to do so
far
is get my republican friends to get in
the game of making things better in this
country i did not anticipate that
there'd be such a
stalwart effort to make sure that the
most important thing was that president
biden didn't get anything done
think about this what are republicans
for
what are they for
they mean one thing they're for
oh he loved debating a straw man if i
may suggest maybe what the gop would say
they stand for maybe i don't know closed
borders actual borders states rights
federalism protecting the sanctity of
life defending the second amendment
cutting taxes how about energy
independence that might hit gas prices
just a little bit
ensuring your personal freedoms when a
government wants to lock you down and
mandate you
the list goes on and on
what about you and your party joe
what do you stand for
so the difference is
i'm going to be out on the road a lot
making the case around the country with
my colleagues who are up for reelection
and others making the case of what we
did do
and what we want to do
what we need to do
so the answer is joe biden is going to
hit the road more joe
more hearing his incoherence that was
certainly
the answer we were all waiting for was
there an answer in there anywhere
but don't worry he made sure to tell us
what his party stands for and it's only
three letters
bbb
the single best way to take the burden
off middle class and work class folks is
to pass the buildback better piece that
are things that they're paying a lot of
money for it now
if you get to trade off higher gases
you're putting up with higher price of
hamburgers and
gas
versus whether or not you're going to
have to you're going to be able to pay
for
uh education and or
[Music]
child care it's alike i think most
people would make the trade
man that that inspires a lot of
confidence
that's how joe views build back better
it's gonna be painful for you
but it'll win him political points he
thinks
so this is just another example of how
joe doesn't actually care about you
about you he doesn't actually know
what's going on in your life or how
these policies affect you and your
family
but his administration has to stand for
something more than a failed social
spending bill right
well biden has spent a lot of time
trying to federalize our elections you
know that whole constitution thing is
pesky and smearing anyone standing in
his way anyone that doesn't agree with
him is of course a racist
listen to how joe biden characterized
his opponents last week
do you want to be the side the side of
dr king
or george wallace
do you want to be in the side of john
lewis
or bull connor
do you want to be the side of abraham
lincoln or jefferson davis
so if you want to keep the federal
government out of elections somehow
you're bull connor or george wallace or
or jefferson davis
and when biden was pressed on it today
he got angry ah grumpy
and you won't like him when joe look
what i said go back and read what i said
and tell me
if you think i called
anyone who voted on the side of the
position taken by bull connor that they
were bull connor
and that is an interesting reading of
english you you i assume you got into in
the journals because you like to write
we uh we
we just played the tape
i think somebody touched a nerve he had
to explain that two or three times and
he never did
but that's a perfect encapsulation of
biden's speech slash
pre-approved press conference
he tried to gaslight you into believing
our country is doing great
while it goes to hell around him
and when he was pressed on he gets angry
it's your fault it's the republicans
fault you're not smart enough to
understand the amazing things that i've
done for you
today was classic biden
no sizzle
and no substance hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else